mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
the american invitational mathematics
examination or amy for short is a
qualifying test in america for the
international mathematical olympiad
it's a three-hour test with 15 questions
and calculators are not allowed
every answer on the test is an integer
from 0 to 999
of interest is 1984 amy problem 3
but lest you think the problem is
outdated it was also asked in 2019 to 14
year olds in sweden
in triangle abc pick a point p on the
interior
construct lines through p that are
parallel to the sides of abc
now these triangles have areas of 4
9 and 49
what is the area of triangle abc
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so there will be many ways to solve this
problem and if you want to share your
solution method in the comments you can
use this labeling of the diagram
i think this is a little bit of an
alphabet soup so i'm going to explain it
visually
because the lines through p are parallel
all triangles are similar to each other
and they're similar to abc
the area of a triangle is proportional
to its side length squared
another way of saying this is that the
square root of the area is proportional
to the side length of the triangle
the ratio of the areas of these three
triangles is 4 to 9 to 49
because these triangles are similar to
each other the ratio of their sides will
be the square root of the areas
this works out to be two to three to
seven
suppose this side length is two times x
because the triangles are similar this
side length will be 3x and this side
length will be 7x
because all sides are parallel we have
parallelograms and these lengths will be
equal to each other
consequently we can calculate that ac
will have a length that's equal to 12x
the ratio of the sides between abc and
this yellow triangle will be 12 to 2
because it's 12x to 2x
this will simplify to be 6 to 1.
consequently the ratio of their areas
will be 6 squared to 1 squared which
works out to be 36 to 1.
and now we can calculate the answer the
area of triangle abc will be 36 times 4
and therefore the answer is 144
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you